[Musique]
pendant plusieurs années des dizaines de
couples chinois ont vécu dans l'hôtel de
ville de tours un épisode important de
leur vie amoureuse des émotions fortes
qu'ils doivent à jean germain
initiateur du concept des noces
romantiques en touraine il était aussi
l'acteur principal des cérémonies
organisées pour les jeunes mariés
mesdames messieurs
concentrez-vous à renouveler vos voeux
de mariage
je vais vous demander maintenant
d'échanger vos alliances mois d'octobre
en laissant qui viennent d'un peu
partout de pékin de shanghai fait tout
parce qu'ils aiment la qu'ils aiment la
touran
à l'époque tout ça ressemble à un accord
gagnant gagnant
les chinois sont heureux et les
tourangeaux sont fiers fiers de
constater que leur ville peut séduire
les habitants de l'autre bout du monde
fier aussi de susciter l'intérêt des
grands médias nationaux avec par exemple
l'émission envoyé spécial qui consacre
un reportage de 30 minutes à l'opération
des chinois en tenue de mariage dans les
rues de tours cela rameute les badauds
vous est cher dit moi
que c'est quand même ils viennent
d'horizons sûr qu'ils ont choisi cette
ville à l'autre ça vous pèse et chinois
j'adore les chinoises mais chez moi
aussi sympa et c'est pas un peu bizarre
quand même des chinois mais non c'est
pas bizarre c'est normal c'est
maintenant n'y a plus de frontières le
monde là tout le monde à travers ses
frontières on espère y ait ici j'irai
les voir c'est là bas moi en dehors de
la notoriété accrue de la ville sur le
plan international il ya aussi un
intérêt économique à court terme pour
certains commerçants locaux qui font à
l'occasion quelques bonnes affaires en
espèces mais l'objectif est avant tout
l'intérêt économique à long terme
les mariages sont une vitrine pour
rapprocher les entreprises de la région
du marché chinois
en 2010 la ville occupe un pavillon lors
de l'exposition universelle de shanghai
jean germain y célèbre quelques mariages
mais il est accompagné d'une délégation
de chefs d'entreprises qui souhaitent
nouer avec les chinois les relations
durables et plus si affinités c'était
phénoménal
quand vous visitez le
le pavillon le pavillon français quand
vous arriviez en bas vous aviez une
queue qui remontait je sais pas c'était
le pavillon le plus visité le pavillon
de la touran et donc oui on avait une
fierté de voir pour nous c'est une belle
opération
pendant trois ans l'opération est
appréciée y compris par ceux qui n'ont
pas la même étiquette politique que jean
germain l'un des premiers à émettre des
réserves va être le conseiller municipal
pascal ménage nous n'avons pas les
éléments clairs qui permettent de savoir
quelle est l'organisation de cette
manifestation
quels sont les critères précis et quels
sont les éléments qui permettent aux
chinois de pouvoir venir en france car
on sait que c'est un pays qui a encore
des progrès à faire en terme de
démocratie
et quels sont les rouages et les
mécanismes qui permettent de mettre en
place ces mariages à qu'il allait aller
de la complicité le pas citer le flou
concernent essentiellement le rôle joué
par une collaboratrice de jean germain
originaire de taïwan installé à tour
depuis une vingtaine d'années lise anne
est embauché par la mairie en 2008
notamment pour s'occuper des mariages on
lève le menton a fait un joli sourire
organisé ces cérémonies et d'autres
opérations de coopération avec la chine
c'est un travail que l'israël ne peut
pas effectuer le seul pour l'assister
dans ses missions la mairie va passer de
nombreux contrats avec une petite
société dont le siège social est situé
dans une boutique du centre de tours la
sarl times et c'est là que va apparaître
un petit problème d'ordre juridique
la société compte parmi ses principaux
actionnaires une certaine lysanne
dirigeante jusqu'à son embauche par la
mairie elle va ensuite confié la gestion
d'entreprise à son mari tout en gardant
ses parts sociales
un mélange des genres qui a justifié en
2011 par un oubli dû au surmenage
ça c'est une erreur enfin que
d'inattention de ma part j'ai su
toujours resté associé
c'est cette société jusqu'au jusqu'au là
on est amis rose ne protégaient l'année
2011 et pendant tout ce temps là c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment inattention
c'est idiot voilà il faut les
reconnaissez d'erreur 1 mais bon entre
temps dessus ni salariés des sociétés et
cette société
comme dirait zh ont organisé un peu
comme une association à la bâtisse a
comme ça une association familiale qui
va tout de même recevoir et gérer des
sommes supérieures à 800000 euros soit
l'intégralité des appels d'offres émis
par la mairie et l'agglomération pour
ses opérations chinoises na frais causés
tous ces ennuis un monsieur le maire il
est absolument faux vie nous est
évidemment on le savait pas 1
sinon je vois pas comment le service des
marchés de la ville de tours murray
proposé de signer ce genre de choses
mais je pense que ça a été corrigé donc
je pense qu'elle a commis une erreur
mais qui a été corrigé assez assez
rapidement et il n'y a pas de
détournement de fonds de choses comme ça
selon jean germain est la chaîne des
responsabilités s'arrête à la porte de
son bureau
mais c'est à ferrari sur la place
publique alors que son image vient déjà
d'être brouillée par deux autres
polémiques
en janvier 2011 le site rue89 parle dans
son cas d'un emploi presque fictif en
s'appuyant sur un rapport de la cour des
comptes
il révèle que pendant 18 ans le maire de
tours a exercé la fonction d'inspecteur
général de l'éducation nationale avec un
salaire à plein temps mais une activité
beaucoup plus réduite entre 1993 et 2010
la cour n'a trouvé pour seule trace de
son activité que quelques notes
manuscrites et un rapport ces
révélations n'ont pas eu de conséquence
pénale mais pour le principal syndicat
de l'éducation nationale il y avait bien
à cette époque deux catégories
d'inspecteurs ceux qui travaillaient
vraiment et les ondes ce quelqu'un qui
est un conseiller général de base ou
petites merdes une toute petite mairie
etc à une activité professionnelle on
peut considérer qu'il peut mener les
deux de front par contre avec le
développement de la décentralisation et
les responsabilités accrues des guides
et des élus locaux
on sent bien qu'à un moment donné
certaines activités sont absolument
incompatibles et dans une période où on
restreint les emplois il est à un peu
problématique pour le moins de constater
que lia des fonctionnaires qui sont
censés exerce une mission est en fait ne
le font pas parce que leur mandat
électif les pros à plein temps
peu actif au sein de l'éducation
nationale jean germain a en revanche
consacré beaucoup de temps à sa ville
notamment au chantier du tramway
un dossier qui lui a valu des soupçons
de favoritisme
puisque le marché du design a été
attribuée à l'une de ses adjointes
la créatrice régine charvet pello
préféré à des concurrents installés dans
d'autres villes pourquoi régine charvet
pello qui fait des trois mois et quand
même je le rappelle à alger à rabat à
mulhouse
partout dans le monde qui travaille sur
ce sujet parce pourquoi pascal et
adjointe à tours sa société serait
écartée j'allais dire de 2 to à partir
du moment où elles concourent dans les
mêmes conditions que les autres est
absolument aucune raison qu'elles soient
écartés
régine charvet pello at-elle concouru
dans les mêmes conditions que les autres
c'est une question que la justice a dû
se poser à la demande d'une conseillère
municipale d'opposition avec une
association d'usagers elle avait déposé
une plainte pour prise illégale
d'intérêt que le parquet a décidé
finalement de classer au motif que c'est
le syndicat des transports et non la
mairie directement qui avait choisi sa
prestataires ce qui nous a vraiment
gêner leur classement sans suite
c'est la raison liminaire devant la
régie ne savais pas mais ces quatre là
c'est sûr que c'est pas elle qui a signé
alors on fait dire à la limite je crois
que personne n'aurait besoin d'étudier
le dossier pour
avoir un avis sur la question donc on a
trouvé que c'était un petit peu court et
que pour nous les choses étaient
beaucoup plus complexe que celle là
[Musique]
l'histoire mise en examen pour
escroquerie l'ancien chargé de mission
auprès de la mairie de tours qui s'est
notamment occupé de l'organisation des
fameux mariage à chinois auraient
présenté des factures sans justificatifs
également poursuivi pour recel de biens
publics et prise illégale d'intérêt elle
devrait bientôt s'expliquer devant la
chambre de l'instruction de la cour
d'appel d'orléans début 2013 cette fois
la justice pousse ses investigations
lysanne est mise en examen pour
escroquerie prise illégale d'intérêt et
recel de fonds publics
les juges implique dans la même
procédure son mari et son ex-mari
actionnaires de la société time et il ne
s'arrête pas là le directeur de l'office
du tourisme est lui aussi mis en examen
soupçonnés d'avoir créé un emploi fictif
pour accueillir les ânes après son
départ forcé de la mairie cette fois
entre le maire de tours et son ex
collaboratrice
on est passé d mariage au divorce
monsieur germain se disant oui on a
embauché madame anne parce que attention
et d associer des sociétés elle était au
principal gérante d'une société
ça doit être une erreur c'est quand même
les rams d'actifs
narry savait très bien qu'on y fait et
on est attribuée marché à une société et
à savoir qu'est ce qui était dit amendes
émises et l'a jamais rien caché
on va supposer que cette époque c'est à
pau fait son travail
n'importe quel artisan du dimanche ont
extrait k bis et à justifier nous ceci
dit si vous cela que vous êtes à jour
des cotisations urssaf et c'est la même
chose alcaniz ou si on n'a pas fait
c'est pas de sa faute
dans les semaines qui viennent les juges
devront vérifier si tout est bien normal
dans les factures réglées par la mairie
à la société time
et pour ça il pourra avoir besoin
d'entendre jean germain protégé pour
l'instant par son immunité parlementaire
avance à l'avocat de lisanne plaidera en
juin devant le tribunal des prud'hommes
car elle attaque son ex employeur pour
licenciement abusif
ce qui pourrait donner lieu à un grand
déballage l'affairé déjà sur la place
publique à la une des journaux et dans
les séances du conseil municipal
même quand il ne figure pas à l'ordre du
jour le sujet est devenu inévitable
je m'interroge sur la situation d'une de
vos anciennes salariées qui a été l'une
de vos proches collaboratrices dans le
cadre d'une certaine manifestation
ancienne collaboratrice qui aujourd'hui
vous traduis aux prud'hommes et qui de
surcroît vous réclame 150 mille euros de
dommages et intérêts j'y vois là encore
la suite logique est inéluctable une
gestion non transparente de ce dossier
que je dénonce depuis maintenant trois
ans monsieur le maire vous m'aviez
indiqué il y avait quelques temps que
j'aurai accès aux pièces de ce dossier
dans le reste très bien sûr de la
confidentialité
vous n'avez pas tenu votre promesse à la
suite de mes interventions votre mutisme
vis-à-vis des médias sur ce dossier
laisse planer inévitablement le doute
dans l'esprit des tourangeaux peu bavard
sur ce sujet jean germain est encore
moins depuis que le dossier dans les
mains de la justice
mais ce jour-là il n'évite pas
complètement la question en ce qui
concerne la chine on n'a pas eu de
chance avec un certain nombre de sujets
mais c'est un beau projet il le demeure
et j'espère si je suis réélu avec mon
équipe pouvoir commencer dans quelques
années parce qu'on a quand même gagné le
prix d'atout france avec ça comme étant
la meilleure idée sur l'année 2010
jean germain ne se prononcera pas sur
d'éventuelles irrégularités comptables
mais il assume encore son objectif de
départ selon lui les centaines de
milliers d'euros investis par la mairie
n'ont pas été dépensés en pure perte
peut-on estimer les retombées
économiques de l'opération c'est ce que
nous avons cherché à savoir avec les
rares chiffres disponibles notamment
ceux du comité régional du tourisme le
tourisme chinois représente 16 mille
nuitées d'hôtel par an sur l'ensemble de
la région essentiellement concentrée sur
la touraine on est très loin des 250
milles ni représentée par les
britanniques
mais le chiffre est en augmentation
constante depuis quelques années du côté
des châteaux on essaye aussi les attirer
même s'il ne représente qu'un an et demi
pour cent du total de la clientèle
étrangère
c'est une clientèle qui est assez peu
nombreuses si vous voulez en pourcentage
on est sur les petits pourcentages mais
ce qui est intéressant évidemment c'est
les perspectives est de constater aussi
que l'évolution d'une année sur l'autre
est de l'ordre de 20% d'envoyer il ya
peu de marché qui évolue à ce rythme en
boîte mais aussi à chenonceau ou que lui
sait où à villandry on a été très
attentif aux noces romantiques en
touraine
certains châteaux associés autrefois aux
opérations de la mairie organise
aujourd'hui leur propre cérémonie
nous avons accueilli un certain nombre
de change chinoises qui sont venus faire
les photographies de mariés chinois qui
sont déjà mariés en fait qui sa vie à
l'occidentale pour faire un certain
nombre de photos c'est plutôt des
voyages de lune de miel qu'ils font en
france
donc voilà un certain nombre de choses
qui sont faites et puis par hasard
d'année dernière nous avons eu un
fabricant le principal fabricant de
robes de mariées chinoise qui est venu
ici à amboise et qui a fait les photos
de son catalogue
ici dans le château avec ses mannequins
du côté de les entrepreneurs on constate
aussi une évolution positive des
affaires avec la chine
le démarrage coïncide avec les
différentes opérations lancées par la
mairie tout ce qu'a fait la mairie
peuvent favoriser développer les
relations avec la chine bien sûr étaient
bienvenus et je pense que ça a apporté
son lot effectivement de business mais
c'est difficile c'est difficile à
chiffrer quoi l'an dernier en 2012
c'était jouant 400 millions d'euros
d'exportations vers la chine donc c'est
quelque chose qui est voulu et c'est une
évolution à deux chiffres depuis de
puisse encore les initiatives de la
mairie ont donc engendrer quelques
retombées économiques mais pour le maire
le bilan politique s'inscrit clairement
dans la colonne négative alors que
démarre la bataille des élections
municipales
certains de ses alliés potentiels sont
déjà obligés de prendre leurs distances
ça rend compliqué si c'est ce que vous
voulez me faire dire de faire
éventuellement des alliances de premier
tour avec le parti socialiste il ya une
mise en examen du maire ça c'est évident
que sa robe beaucoup plus compliqué d
alliance de premier tour
ensuite il ya des responsabilités
différentes au second tour parce qu'il
s'agit de voir si la ligue face à l'ump
ou reste dans le cadre de la majorité
présidentielle masse et d'autres
responsabilités et d'autres évaluations
à faire si c'est politique
la mise en examen de jean germain est
une hypothèse qui ne semble aujourd'hui
pas impossible dans les salons de
l'hôtel de ville
l'heure n'est plus à la fête il arrive
parfois que l' aventure du mariage se
termine dans le bureau du juge et à tour
quelques mètres seulement séparent la
mairie du tribunal
[Musique]